understanding IQ no Marshall context
part three so in the latter videos we
had talked about what Marshall context
is so it's the situation you're going to
be using your Marshall ardian how there
are many different martial contexts
right so there's situations involving
weapons there's unarmed situations
there's multiple attackers situations
different environments to be fighting in
many many different contexts in which
you can possibly be using the word
martial art to describe a system form
and there's also a interest for some
reason in the modern world for one when
we say the word martial art to be
describing a one-on-one unarmed
situation and within this realm of
one-on-one unarmed situations very
recently mixed martial arts has appeared
to do a nice job of dominating this
conflict and this context and showing
that we really have kind of figured out
the most important parts to this context
so for the unarmed one-on-one context
all the things that are going to work
the best in MMA is no doubt one of the
best avenues to take to study that right
now but there are other contexts and MMA
hasn't helped us understand these other
contexts so for example whatever may did
within the realm of unarmed one-on-one
it helped us figure out some of the sub
contexts right so what happens when a
kickboxer versus a regular boxer is
punching so important that a kickboxer
really doesn't have a big advantage or
does the kickboxer have such an
advantage with kicking that he's able to
beat the the regular boxer up and in
questions like this have been answered
for us by MMA within that that context
on our one-on-one MMA has done a great
job of figuring that out for us what
what's important invalid however there
are other contexts so for example when
someone has a sword MMA hasn't told us a
lot to do with someone with a sword or
was someone with a gun or if you're
fighting in a crazy situation in the
dark or if you're fighting in the cold
or if you're fighting and someone comes
out behind you need and expect the
person to be there in uncontrolled
situations MMA hasn't done a great job
of helping us understand them better
I you know has a context that I believe
I cure does a great job of explaining to
us and telling us the techniques we're
going to need for this context is to
part its multiple attacker and weapon
oriented so weapon oriented means that
it could be I'm armed or you're armed or
both armed it could and multiple
attackers means there were always
suspecting that there's going to be
another person involved so we're never
just focusing in on one person and it
being just just us in them so looking at
this context vs MMA you can see these
are these are dramatically different
contexts in fact they're kind of
opposite in every way one on one unarmed
is exactly the opposite of armed or
weapon oriented and multiple attackers
so you can't expect one context to
answer questions about the other so I
kiddo being a martial art that's very
focused on armed multiple attackers
situations is going to do miserably in a
situation where there's just one person
and we're unarmed now it might seem at
first like that's not true because you
might say well if you can beat up
multiple people while they're armed then
how come you can't deal with one person
one-on-one and that is a way of looking
at it but kind of a fallacious way of
looking at it there are specifics about
the situations that will change what's
going on so for example when I'm
specifically trying to compete against a
person that's very different than trying
to survive a situation so if I'm gonna
give em a ring with somebody and my
solution is to just keep getting away
from them to keep moving away from them
so they can never do anything to me and
I'm not going to hurt them but I'm just
going to keep moving away I'm going to
lose the MMA match because I'm running
from the other person we're there to
compete where they're just physically
specifically compete over in a
life-or-death situation where I managed
to avoid someone had never get killed
that's a win for me it's a big victory
for me so understanding what the
differences are and why those
differences are important is the first
key to understanding I kido and what's
important about it so we're going to
make one more addition to this the next
video is going to cover what the
specifics are and why you can see that I
kiddo is a
weapons oriented system dealing with
multiple attackers versus a one-on-one
unarmed situation and why techniques for
one might not necessarily be good
techniques for the other I'm Christopher
hi and thanks a lot for watching